il ya une femme elle est absente et
l'auteur lui les présents on peut
affirmer ça parce qu'il dit un seul être
vous manque et tout est dépeuplé à la
poule appelé aussi écoles laboratoires
ce sont les élèves qui font cours
le travail se fait par atelier en
groupes restreints pour favoriser les
échanges et la prise de parole ce matin
les élèves travaillent sur un poème de
lamartine
il tente de trouver un sens au texte
sans être particulière l'objectif va
être de favoriser les expérimentations
pédagogiques qui vise à la
différenciation et à l'individualisation
des parcours en prenant en compte les
besoins de chaque élève
on montre aussi l'intérêt de ce qui a
été vu ailleurs
parce que souvent les élèves ont du mal
à transférer à réinvestir une notion ou
une compétence vu dans une autre matière
ou dans un cours d'accompagnement
personnalisé
ce dispositif ouvert à la rentrée de
septembre permet aux élèves en
difficulté comme à ceux qui ont plus de
facilité de travailler ensemble pour
oeuvrer à la réussite de chacun en fait
quand on est sur l'écran il faut casser
focaliser ça peut être mauvais mais là
c'est bon pour travailler je suis pas
dérangé par les autres élèves et j'suis
pas forcément tenté pour bavarder au
laboratoire de mathématiques même
dispositif en petit groupe et avec du
matériel les élèves doivent résoudre un
problème on est loin du cours
académiques
à ce cours il est différent des cours
classiques parce qu'on s'est un peu
comme un jeu parce que quand on en cours
normal on fait des exercices du court
l'objectif c'est déjà de changer un peu
l'image que les élèves ont des
mathématiques
ces deux
montrer qu'en mathématiques on peut
apprendre en manipulant ce dispositif
est en phase de test
une évaluation aura lieu en juin
prochain pour mesurer son impact sur la
progression de l'élève et sa réussite
la réussite des élèves c'est déjà son
épanouissement personnel
effectivement qu'ils puissent découvrir
toutes ces potentialités ça c'est
quelque chose d'important et parfois
certains jeunes n'ont pas forcément eu
la possibilité on n'aura pas forcément
donné la possibilité de le faire
et qu'après derrière effectivement le
champ des possibles s'ouvre pour lui
en partenariat avec des laboratoires de
recherche le lycée parriat devient donc
un lieu d'expérimentation pédagogique ou
élèves comme professeurs dessinent
ensemble le lycée du futur